- [Announcer] Seeking secrets
is a social experiment
where strangers share
honest and complex truths.
We ask that you treat the
participants with respect.
Thank you for listening to their stories.
- [1st Woman] My ex-boyfriend
said he would kill himself
if he wasn't with me.
I call in my ex because he's gone.
I've been feeling grief
for two months now.
(gentle music)
(telephone ringing)
- [2nd Woman] You died.
- [3rd Woman] A few
Months later, she died.
- [4th Woman] I've lost loved ones
and I've also had friends who
have struggled significantly
with grief, but I can
never tell those friends
that I'm often very suicidal.
I maintain this sunny disposition to hide
what I've been going through
but as they're coping
with loss, I'm coping
with the effects that losing my own life
might have on their life.
- Oh no.
I sit in the same position
as her, every single day.
My mom who has done the most
for me I feel like I can't even tell her
how I feel sometimes because the times
where it's gotten really,
really bad seeing her feel
like she's going to lose
me has hurt me so bad.
- Sometimes putting on a sunny disposition
is trying to protect other people
and sometimes it's also
trying not to address
maybe what's going on with me,
and so you use it as like a
hiding mechanism for yourself
as well as for other people.
And it is a dangerous thing
to feel kind of that alone.
I'd highly encourage this person
that they might be surprised if they share
how they're feeling with their friends.
- [5th Woman] When I
was like 12 years old me
and my two brothers were
told that my grandfather
had passed away of a heart attack.
It was really sad, first like
death I had to go through
and then fast forward
like two years later,
maybe more than that I'm
snooping through my mom's phone
and I find her Reddit account
and on her Reddit account, she detailed
how my grandfather are
actually committed suicide.
They just told me he had a heart attack
because they didn't wanna explain
the concept of suicide to me.
He had died two years ago
but now I'm grieving all over again
and for something completely different.
And I can't tell my family
- It must really hurt because they say
they can't tell other
people or tell their family.
Like it hurts that they can't mourn
in the way they usually do.
- I would understand why
she wouldn't wanna tell
her children how he actually did it
cause I know that suicide is
a very hard topic to discuss.
- I can't imagine being
an adult trying to explain
really big topics to a kid because
I don't know what I would do.
The first death in my life
I wasn't told what actually happened.
I actually was also told
it was a heart attack.
It's almost like you
have to solve a puzzle
before you can grieve when it
comes to that kind of stuff.
Especially when you're younger.
For this specific person they didn't keep
that information from you to hurt you.
It was to actually protect you.
- [6th Woman] So I've grown up in
the Bible Belt my entire life
and earlier this year, my
cousin died by suicide.
Previous to this, I removed myself
from religion it's probably
been about a year now
when the time came for
the funeral, all people
could keep saying and talking
about was thank goodness
he was saved two months
before he died.
And they kept repeating it
over and over and over again.
And in those moments I was so angry
because I know that
there were people there
at his funeral who thought
that he probably went to hell.
- It's very unfortunate
at a time like a funeral
for people to discuss
things like that but that may
just be their way of coping.
Suicide is a very hard thing
to conceptualize especially
when it's your loved ones.
So relying on faith is
definitely something
that is an anchor for
a lot of people to get
through stuff like this.
- After I lost my sister,
the judgment that I just saw
from the church when I
wasn't actively going back
after the loss, I just, oh
man, I relate to that so well.
- [1st Man] My 15-year-old brother took
his own life three years ago.
Everyday I struggled with forgiving him
because it seemed like a very
selfish and weak thing to do.
- My dad took his own life two
days before my 10th birthday.
And,
it ripped the family apart
pretty significantly.
And I remember I had woken up
the night that he had passed
and I had dialed his number I was
like, "I just wanna talk to him so bad."
And then I never did.
And for the longest time I was
like, "that would've
made all the difference."
I find that I'm angriest
in moments of transition.
So like graduating from high school or
getting a new job, moments where it's
like I wish he was here
to see what I'm doing.
Maybe it's too easy to
say we all make mistakes
cause that's a pretty big mistake.
- I hope he can forgive his brother
and more than forgive
is accept his suffering
and the choice he made
and life's different for everybody.
And I think acceptance is like
the right path towards peace.
- [1st Woman] My ex-boyfriend
said he would kill himself
if he wasn't with me.
I call him my ex because he's gone.
I've been feeling grief
for two months now.
- Someone very close to me when
I was younger was suffering
with depression and was very suicidal
and I was really the only person that knew
what they were going through.
I had went home and told my mom
because this time it was real.
I never talked to her after that.
I was receiving messages from my friend
about how much she hated
me for doing what I did.
- [interviewer] If you could say something
to your 12-year-old self,
what would you tell her?
- I would say that I'm proud of her.
- [7th Woman] I lost my
best friend from suicide
when I was 23.
I used to do a of drugs
so I can see her again
and it was just crazy times
after I stopped doing drugs,
I kind of forgot about her
and then I think that's
better for me to forget
about her than actually think about her
because there's no point when
she's not even here anymore.
- I feel sad for this person
that they feel like they
should just forget about them.
That that's gonna make it better.
I can't imagine just forgetting
even the shirt I'm wearing
this is my husband's shirt.
I haven't gotten rid of anything
and I don't plan on
it, to forget anything.
My husband hung himself
and to this day,
it's almost like a video saved in my mind
of exactly walking in the house.
I struggled a lot with
seeing him all the time
and that still happens at times.
I'll be driving and I'll
look through my mirror
and look into my backseat
and I see him with a rope around his neck,
how I found him.
I don't know, I wish
that I remembered more
of the happy stuff, but it's difficult.
It's just like there.
- [8th Woman] I had a
friend who passed away in
the winter of 2018 and on
the two-year anniversary
of his death, he came to me in a dream.
And in this dream, he gave
me a really, really long hug
and then he told me, "I know that
this isn't okay to ask of you
but you could always join me
here, I'm always so lonely."
And I told him I can't because
there are too many things
that I have to look forward to.
He told me, "that's okay,
just promise me we'll hang out
once you get here,"
and I think about that
dream at least once a week.
- So I actually have so
many dreams about my friend.
She comes to me at least like once a month
but it's the same dream every single time.
And I see her and I'm
like, "oh my God, Maya,"
like, "where have you been?"
Like, "I miss you so much."
And she's like, "I've been in school,"
and she's always in school.
I graduated college almost a year ago.
She would've graduated at the same time.
But she's still in college in my head
since she never really graduated, I guess.
- I hope that dream fades for her, I guess
because I know my husband is happy
for me of how far I've come.
It's not been an easy one since he passed,
but I know that he wouldn't
want me to join him just yet.
I know my husband is somewhere
where his heart is at peace
and I know he's painting
somewhere, listening to music,
probably Mac Demarco or Kid
Cudi having probably a taco.
- It's really easy to say it gets better.
We need to say that to each other I think.
But it's really hard to believe
or to understand that it does get better.
Cause people would say
that to me all the time
and like you wanna slap them.
I once woke up in like
a pool of my own blood.
I remember being a little
upset that I woke up.
But I'm so glad I did.